[Music]  we shared our love story and I feel that  I'm doing I'm honoring that it's nothing  bad it's coming from love Prince's first  wife Micah Garcia is speaking out  detailing her most intimate moments with  the late music icon  [Music]  Garcia shares everything in a new memoir  the most beautiful my life with prints  including the 1996 death of their infant  son he only lived six days and the  former dancer opened up to Good Morning  America about their choice to keep it a  secret for so long  it was just escalated because it was it  was Prince's son and it was our son and  it was but it was how he handled it and  I respected that it's been nearly a year  since Prince's death after an accidental  overdose Garcia says she never saw signs  of drug abuse while they were together  [Music]